[Music]
kimberly is in san antonio hi kimberly
welcome to the ramsay show
hi dave how you doing today better than
i deserve how can we help
i'm a little nervous right now it's okay
we've never lost a patient
okay
thank you thank you
um so we we're an active duty uh family
thank you for your service
thank you i appreciate it um i just have
some questions all my questions are
related up to our military lifestyle
i guess my first question is going to be
about the
service members civil relief act
um how we can use that in our advantage
um in my for us personally we don't uh
we have zero percent interest in all of
our credit cards
due to that act
and how can we use that enough in our
advantage that would be
uh my first question
um
i can go into the others but i don't
really want to tackle these well the
biggest thing there is that the service
relief act gives us two things one is
you've got the zero percent that you're
able to say okay 100 of what i pay on
this
credit card debt goes on the principal
so it's a real opportunity uh while
apparently someone is
not only active duty but deployed into a
combat zone right
correct yeah but um
yeah it it has varieties but we have
been participating for a few years
already okay then you're in there good
so yeah so a hundred percent of what you
pay on these credit cards is going to
get rid of them so chop them up and
let's list them smallest to largest as
far as the debt rate goes and attack
them with a vengeance the other part of
the act that sometimes folks have to use
and we've used in financial coaching
with the military for years
is that if you are behind on something
like a behind on a car payment or behind
on rent or behind on a house payment the
creditor cannot foreclose or repossess
on you because you're falling to that
act
uh until you guys get back and
everybody's you know not deployed into a
combat zone and get back active and so
forth but that's probably not gonna
apply to you but the whole thing is when
you got zero percent instead of eighteen
percent you know let's take advantage of
that and use that extra that same thing
with those those of you sitting on
student loans right now you have zero
percent so let's let's just use this
time not to sit around and twiddle our
thumbs and go oh we don't have to be in
a hurry we have zero percent no this is
get in a hurry time
yeah and that's what we're seeing it
reminded me of the student loan extended
relief where it's zero percent people go
well i'm going to take advantage of this
but the real way to take advantage of it
is to pay off all your debt and get rid
of it so i don't know how much debt
kimberly has on this or if she's just
saying how do i take advantage of this
card going forward there is no way to
take advantage of debt that's not really
a gift yeah it takes advantage of you